[Music]
[Applause]
got alright everyone that's a wrap
movies love quicksand and why not it's
exotic its dramatic and it's highly
exaggerated fun fact it's impossible to
become fully submerged in quicksand but
what could happen to you this is what if
and here's what would happen if you fell
into quicksand the reason why you don't
normally sink into the sand when you go
to the beach is due to a physics
phenomenon known as force change
basically when a bajillion grains of
sand are jammed together in one place
their weight gets distributed over a
large area keeping you and your camels
safely above ground but if any water
happens to seep up from underground it
will mix with the sand to create a
surface that looks solid what is it it's
true that real quicksand isn't like what
you see at the movies the reason why you
won't sink right three is because
quicksand is rarely more than a few feet
deep and even if it was deeper than that
humans are only half as dense as
quicksand
so really you couldn't sink much lower
than your waist that is unless you
struggle quicksand is a non-newtonian
fluid meaning its viscosity changes
under stress in high-stress conditions
like being under the weight of your body
quicksand changes it becomes liquid
causing you to sink so if you panic and
start frantically trying to get out the
rapid shifting of your weight will only
suck you down deeper and faster on the
other hand quicksand gets thicker over
time so if you just hang around and do
nothing it'll be harder for you to get
out every minute you're stuck in
quicksand
increases the risk that you'll suffer
from dehydration starvation sunstroke or
hypothermia and if that doesn't give you
chills those hungry looking eyes might
depending on where you are you might
even drown
quicksand is often found near the sea
because it's easier for water to rise up
through the sand so if you're ever
caught in the coast be sure to keep an
eye on the time at best you'll only have
six hours before the tide changes but if
not trying to escape and trying too hard
are both bad choices then what are you
supposed to do if you get stuck in
quicksand the trick is to stay calm
first get rid of any heavy items that
you're wearing or carrying as they'll
only drag you deeper then try to lean as
far back as you can to create more space
for yourself water will come in and fill
the gaps you create which will make it
easier for you to move and pull your
body towards the surface if you can grab
a stick and wedge it underneath your
back this will help to increase your
leverage hopefully you'll get help from
emergency services but if not you can
use these tips to get out on your own
it will be a long and exhausting process
since just to free your foot from a
puddle of quicksand moving at a rate of
one centimeter per second it would
require the same amount of force as it
does to lift a small car and once you're
free you'll probably be in a lot of pain
with all that pressure from the densely
packed sand you might emerge from the
quicksand with permanent nerve damage or
without a leg if you do manage to come
out in one piece
well maybe tread a little more carefully
in the future but don't let this one
sucky experience keep you from another
adventure
put your best foot forward and take a
walk on the wild side next time on what
if